[Music]
ah
this is just some of the headlines that
were written about me
russell brand is moving to syria i'm
[__] not
there he is ladies and gentlemen russell
brandt hello you said you fancy jennifer
lawrence sure she's a really beautiful
oscar-winning actress i wouldn't go i
refuse to have sex with this glorious
creation at one minute i'm a fat little
boy and i'm nervous and i'm frightened
that i'm not good enough at fighting or
football i've been a junkie i've lived
on benefits then i've been in hollywood
and like lived that kind of life and i
sort of seen that and been inside it and
flash bulbs
and camera ended up against the side of
the car and all the things that come
with that hugo boss made the uniforms
for the nazis but he might not know
didn't ring any bells it's sort of a
giddy thrilling insane enjoyable thing
and it doesn't surprise me that some
people it that it either kills them or
they can't ever ever get out of it and
they'll do anything to hold on to it so
while i'm waiting to meet the queen and
she's edging along shaking the hands of
the other performers i'm trying to
remember all them rules all them
protocols part of my mind is thinking
grab a [__] tip
i really wanted all those things that
people want i wanted to feel valuable
and powerful and well-off rich and
appreciated and because i was lucky
enough to experience those things i can
no longer live in the suspension of that
illusion i've been shown that it's not
real it's still attractive if you look
at the things associated with it like
glamour glamour is seductive i might get
some little
boost from one of those things but
ultimately i will suffer when i'm guided
by am i being of service am i trying to
help other people am i being kind am i
being honest then i start to operate in
alignment with a set of values and
principles that are older than me that
are more powerful than me that are
deeper than me still comes with loads of
mistakes errors hypocrisy not perfection
i know what i'm looking for a little bit
now tonight calls for the two stars to
be sacked as ofcom launches an
investigation there were some of the
things that you did back in the day
and i just thought
[Music]
there he is ladies and gentlemen russell
brand in the flesh
the beautiful man himself hello you're
rather beautiful
yes thank you thank you so much for
having me thank you for coming thanks
for coming yeah it's lovely to see you
so you used to come here when you were
younger then yeah when i was um when i
was a kid like i was looked after by a
management company there
also i went to drama school and that was
around the corner yeah you weren't the
only white house's drama school is that
right oh one of them special heroine not
another school for children just quite
tired you're interested in acting and
heroin come to
and michael fassbender they were like
tom michael fassbender was a couple of
years below so like around here yeah
it's so it's so weird now that i live in
the countryside just to come into this
just to come into the city and just you
know to be to be it's weird it's like
the memories are like physical objects
strewn on the street things that you
don't think about unless you go back
there when you go back to them places
there it is strewn with nostalgia i
could listen to him talk a while good
nostalgia yeah keep going keep going
that's not gonna there's not gonna be
any questions
keep going just reflect just yeah well
nostalgia does have the sort of same
root as pain in it yeah then it's like
like as you know like analgesia and all
that kind of stuff things
do you feel any of that when you're
around these areas that you used to
knock around and when those
times in your life were a bit harder no
i feel gratitude i feel great in a way i
feel gratitude for sometimes i think
about that because like often when you
think about your past if you're crazy
and you've done crazy stuff you think
god what was he doing that kid but
nothing i'm grateful to him because now
i like live yeah i mean i've got like
kids i'm married my life is calm i feel
like i'm moving in the right direction
and i feel like that little geezer he
went for all that so that i could live
this much more
easy life where i'm more connected some
of it was properly mental because yeah
this is what i was a smackhead in the
crackheads around here like this sort of
you know a lot of them there's a lot of
them around you if i'm honest they're
still still
they're on the same trajectory they're
not they're not those proud traditions i
come down like i come because where i've
come from i've come down the hill from
swiss cottage and i went past a block of
flats where goldie used to live i was
reliably informed and where i once while
scoring got shot at by what my mate matt
morgan insists i always describe as by a
tiny gun
a tiny gun because the sound of the
bullet hitting the car was
like it wasn't like could have still
killed you could have certainly i think
if it could have chafed yeah had it made
impact chafing can kill what does it
feel like to be shot at russell
well i've you know these are tough times
on the streets and i think the reason
that my mate insisted i would describe
it as a tiny gun is to ensure that i
didn't later down the line try to
glamorize that
being very gangster you know you're
talking about you're on the the right
track and feeling like you're on the
right path
you you confuse me a little bit because
most people who are in
the game of uh social media now and
putting their opinions out there they'd
rather just be rich and not really have
to do that you kind of you you kind of
went the other way where you you had all
the fame and then you thought actually i
don't really want to do the whole
pretending to be other people acting and
all of that and i'm going to put my
actual opinions across and leave myself
up there to be shot at why why bother
you know because you you could just
chill enjoy life be in the countryside
forget the world's problems i think
broncos what's real in the end because
i've like because when i was
a kid growing up in greys and then when
i was a teenager and a young man round
here
i really wanted all those things that
people want i wanted to feel valuable
and powerful and well-off rich and
appreciated
and because i was lucky enough to
experience those things
i can no longer live in the suspension
of that illusion i've been shown that
it's not real it's still attractive if
you look at the things associated with
it like glamour glamour is seductive you
know like glamour as a verb vampires
glamorize their victims you know so like
those sort of things are still like
they're attractive if you engage with
them and indulging them and even seeing
your great success here the wonderful
paraphernalia the bear brick wood floors
throughout in a lovely herringbone
pattern someone noticed lovely see
people care about interiors you know
it's nice to be you know successful it's
nice to see beautiful things but it's um
it's um it's a demonstration of what's
real it's not what is real in itself
it's well easy to get like think about
what's happening just for example with
football it maintains its visceral
appeal the real connection you see that
with something like the esl that people
are enraged by it but what is it most of
the time betting companies advertising
just
corporatized a sense of dislocation but
something real remains within it so i've
had a little life that showed me i come
from a normal background i've been a
junkie i've lived on benefits then i've
been in hollywood and like lived that
kind of life and i sort of seen that and
been inside it and flash bulbs
and camera lenses up against the side of
the car and all the things that come
with that
and because like i come here from a
junky and addict perspective i know that
really there's just something in you
that wants that wants that's looking for
something and if you're lucky enough to
get those things or see those things
then you recognize it ain't real and so
you the second part of your life if you
are interested in awakening becomes
about integrity and authenticity still
comes with loads of mistakes errors
hypocrisy not perfection but at least
you're at least i suppose in this
instance i know what i'm looking for a
little bit now but you're tackling it in
a different way aren't you like when you
first did trues
me and me and lawrence were like massive
fans of you what you were doing and it
felt like you were starting a bit of a
movement there and you're really
challenging the powers that be and you
were becoming a bit of a
you they were a bit frightened to you
because you were saying don't vote and
[__] and people were like yeah and i was
saying it watching you like yeah [__]
them what is the point um they're all
corrupt they're all crooks and then you
sort of you kind of come at it from a
different angle as you've gotten a bit
older and gone a bit more like
i'm presenting you with information make
your own mind up and maybe not as
putting your balls on the line too it
gets a bit scary don't it mate ain't you
already had with your success like what
happens when you're in a different
position at whatever level you
experience it now if you get involved in
things that actually affects power and
the flow of power even in a small way
you kind of get a little bit of kickback
from it
so
because when i was doing that trues i
was still bouncing right out of the the
um what i want to say the sort of the
echo of you know being an actor and
being involved in all that stuff i was
still running quite a lot on
ego
so i was really excited by that like you
know when like sort of the leader of the
opposition come around my house for an
interview when they're saying my name in
the houses of parliament russell brown
like when the then prime minister has to
coat me off i'm thinking hang on this is
mad
my mate again matt who i'm beginning to
see is a problematic influence like he
goes like he goes you're having such an
impact it's ridiculous for having
feedback because he's known me for a
long time it's ridiculous for having
this impact he goes i think if you said
that people should vote like they would
probably influence the outcome of the
election some little part of me
flattered at that
i can win elections like a little bit of
a mania inside me still dormant come
alive and i thought i will endorse that
ed miliband so because like um
because of that that sort of tendency
towards madness silliness
you know that weren't the right time for
me to be doing that kind of stuff
because actually even i'm being sort of
a bit silly about my own like ego and
that this is a mental mental time we've
known for a long time we've known for a
long time that powerful institutions and
powerful interests are not
actually benefiting the lives of
ordinary people it's becoming clearer
and clearer more plain and situations
and channels like yours platforms like
this one do present a possibility for a
more open discourse it's hard to manage
their their
power that they give you to speak
truthfully and honestly and openly the
risks that come with doing something
like that the responsibilities that come
with something like that and and what
my or your or any of our limitations are
as individuals you know you can only
really be in the service of bigger
things bigger ideas
when for me when it starts coming about
myself which can happen pretty easily
i get in trouble yeah i've i've seen you
talk about joe rogan and some of the
things he's going through now as he
grows
in power in america and it's not
something he's trying to do he's
literally just being an honest guy bit
like yourself and they're coming after
him
in in the worst way actually like i've
not seen
a solo entertainer go through what he's
going through with just by having a
conversation cnn or trying to make out
like he's a crazy man it's unprecedented
because he's in an unprecedented
situation a lot of things have come
together like the the you know the
platform the success of that the the
medium in general and then the way that
he has landed
i don't i wouldn't claim to
like i i know him a bit you know i mean
i've been on there a couple of times
it's not like someone i know super well
but i know him a bit and what i was
struck by is he's grounded you know his
background obviously is well aware he's
in fighting and martial arts and i think
that gives him a different kind of
grounding he's not a person
like
even the second time i went on there
when it was sort of already like a
massive podcast he already like he's
only got a couple of people he's not his
operation ain't as swanky as this you
know yeah
yeah it's just like it's just like you
know imminent blood he's just pottering
around he don't care he's not trying to
get anything like sometimes when i think
about right how do i reach more people
how do i ensure success in this area joe
rogan he doesn't do none of that stuff
he's i think like legit and authentic
and they must hate the fact that he's so
um he's got so much integrity and there
aren't that the skeletons in his closet
are so minor compared to the politicians
that they're like how do we take this
guy down you know it must be doing their
heads in also because the what he's
achieving financially is you can't
undermine that like spotify you know
what their sort of priorities are as an
organization we have a sort of a rough
idea the way that those look that kind
of milieu that technically what their
priorities in perspective is but i can't
do anything about it this is what i
think about the idea of ordinary people
coming together the idea of a movement
emerging out of football fans and a new
kind of uh working and ordinary people
movement the real potential for it even
though in spite of the incredible odds
and the amount of time that's spent
mining your attention distracting you
making your dumb filling you up with
stupid food the fact is is that the
those we oppose have no real ideology
there's nothing behind it except gain
and greed and power so i really
remain really optimistic about the
possibility of change that little
flourish around the truth time it was
sort of exciting for me and now as you
say i approach things differently and
i'm glad that it comes across that way
because i recognize my limitations i
think you're being responsible
more so than before but
the young guy who was like the way i was
i was like i don't know early 20s when i
was watching you then i remember
thinking but i like the fact that you
were
being
aggressive and and saying
what i feel to be true which is that
they're all in it together this is all a
waste of time and you really spoke to
the generation
and um i feel like now i feel more
hopeless than ever in fact do you mate
well don't feel hopeless look that's
precisely what i was trying to do boris
johnson's the prime minister i remember
him from have i got news for you no he
was good on that that's why we voted him
in he was really good on that yeah he
still loves the quiz
he's still really into it yeah everybody
gets all the right answers as well isn't
it strange yeah always
don't feel down about it i know what you
feel because i feel it too you feel like
well what are they going to do get rid
of boris johnson and they knew and what
if labour one kid stopped what's that
what the difference is there is no it's
pretty clear that the way that the game
is set up is to not give you a viable
alternative absolutely and then if you
do protest or it then they shut down
that avenue as well it is to achieve a
kind of stasis because when we feel like
oh things are going wrong things are
falling apart people that are in
positions of power things are not going
wrong and fall apart they're going
exactly as they're supposed yeah
but then they cover that by
boris is the perfect example of someone
who's the bimbling you know the
struggling guy who oh you just can't
seem to string a sentence right together
bless him you know he's such a good
person for them to have as the front man
for chaos
because it it it looks unplanned it
looks like he is just crap at his job
forget covid just start realizing that
you feel more controlled than ever and
that alone means that when they want to
take us further down that road
you're going to go with it more likely
because of every all the mental training
we've had in the last two years i feel
that's why bang on about the spiritual
solution a spiritual solution just means
a connection to who you really are and
what's really important to you and
simple sesame street values like
kindness
service not spending your old time every
single day just thinking about what you
want for yourself if you spend time
cultivating a relationship with your
inner life and by this i mean like say
the wim off breath work meditation
getting yourself within yourself
recognizing who you are establishing
what your priorities are and where those
priorities came from who trained you to
be you who gave you your set of values
who told you who you are but i start to
develop and cultivate a relationship
with yourself because then when crisis
comes when change even comes you you'll
come you know who you are you're coming
from somewhere you know who your allies
are you know how to move forward you at
least have a kind of a some sort of
personal vision while all of us are
spellbound hypnotized again by the bad
food by the additives by the bad
environment just the other like in 24
hours you read like oh they're dumping
raw sewage into the river thames and i
feel like oh my god these are even minor
things this is nothing on the global
scale but the kind of uh the sort of the
lack of foresight the idiocy and greed
that just that just pass as normal
mentality that you don't really sort of
question anymore the lethargy of being
in this world or thinking you can't do
anything i believe that can only be
overcome if you have some some kind of
connection with who you are really again
this is why something like football has
a resonance people come together as a
member of a tribe people come together
with a common purpose as members of a
community there's a power in it there's
a real power in it and this power can be
utilized it can be directed and so that
like i know you mean brian and i feel it
too sometimes i feel frightened
sometimes and i feel hopeless but i
really really believe in people believe
in the people of this country i believe
there is a dormant force waiting to
awaken how do you um the stage now is i
i might have been through a couple of
times where i thought i found that
authentic element and then afterwards it
was revealed to me that maybe i wasn't
as authentic as i thought i was or there
was a bit of a trip after that and i
think a lot of people go through that
they kind of they would like to hit that
authentic
um goal first time and then sort of live
the rest of their life authentically it
can be a little bit tricky sometimes to
find out what is authentic and know what
is authentic and that's always i guess
you find that out throughout your life
but how do you get to that authentic
side of yourself and how do you know
what's authentic and what isn't within
that what's not true what is it well you
see mate there are things that are
revealed through having a meditative
practice that cannot be understood
without undertaking it what i mean by
that say if you see the world in
material and neurological terms it
likely awakens synaptic pathways that
would otherwise be inaccessible but see
i look at the world a bit more
spiritually and i would say that if you
spend time in prayer and meditation you
start to know yourself different and you
start to realize hang on a minute i only
thought that because that thing happened
to me when i was a kid that's the only
reason i've ever felt that hold on a
minute that set of biases and ideas
that's been downloaded into me in the
culture you can do this you can't do
that these people are good these people
are bad
so that once you start to have that kind
of awakening of like who put these
thoughts in my head they're not even my
force then you start to be able to on a
moment by moment basis check your
motivation what is it you're doing and
why i sometimes checking myself and
think am i only saying this or doing
this because i want something because i
want people to like me or because i want
power privilege prestige pleasure those
kind of things when i'm in pursuit of
those ideas i may temporarily be
distracted or i might get some little
boost from one of those things but
ultimately i will suffer when i'm guided
by am i being of service am i trying to
help other people am i being kind am i
being honest then i start to um what do
i want to say operate in alignment with
a set of values and principles that are
older than me that are more powerful
than me that are deeper than me it's
difficult to just be a little individual
and if your little individual life is
live within the confines determined by a
culture that doesn't love you that wants
you like a dumb little commodity
stuffing consumer then what values do
you have but if you start to engage with
very primal deep principles ancient
values
then you're being carried by something
i'm talking really about a religious
idea at least a spiritual idea but not
in a i wouldn't say a doctrine uh or
dogmatic way where i tell you what you
should believe and we all tell each
other what we don't have a fight about
it later certainly not under the
circumstances but like
what i'm saying is there is something in
you you're trying to find that you've
always been trying to find that you've
tasted touched and felt at different
points in your life and then you get
distracted away from it again and that's
certainly in my experience that's normal
even what we've talked about already
like um you know with the obvious
example of pursuing success and thinking
that success means success in the eyes
of others or success means power to
influence and manipulate other people
instead of recognizing that real success
is coming home to who you really are he
said to me one of men that teaches me
life is not a
life is not linear we know that now but
neither is it a circle it's a spiral you
will see the same things again but
hopefully with a deeper understanding or
from a higher perspective
the reason that myths and stories have a
resonance fairy tales folktales
spiritual ideas is because there are
deep truths that keep presenting
themselves to us throughout history that
you're going to have to cross this river
you're going to have to go into that
dark wood you're going to have to
confront the wolf if you ever want to
get to grandma's house you can't get
taken off the path if you ever want to
become the realized archetype the elder
if you want to become that you don't
fall down those traps taking the money
and the honey and the pink and the green
and falling by the wayside
but you know temptation will come
authenticity i suppose means
moment to moment who is governing you
who's controlling you what are you being
dominated by and i don't mean externally
i mean internally even though as we've
already discussed the external situ um
the external systems of domination are
it seems at least to me more potent than
they have ever been
when i was younger i went through a
period of not having a lot of money at
all
and when i got older and i got fortunate
enough to have this situation amazing i
uh i blew a load of money on fast cars
and rubbish like that and then i sort of
had a moment of uh a reality check you
know like what the [__] have i been
doing here this is all [__] seeing
how uh together you are now and how like
sensible you are in your peak of
heading down the hollywood road
uh what was it like pretty amazing for a
bit but like because
what were the best bits but tell us
about the good bits
yeah make it a bit glamorous and
appealing because we want some of that
you know yeah because i'm not a person
who's just been to an all-you-can-eat
buffet at everything and then comes like
oh you just not don't need none of this
yeah exactly go to church shut up start
meditating exactly i'm gonna pop back
for a bit more because pop stars are
overrated yeah i need to be doing that a
shadow that
sit down quietly listen i'm just telling
you right i remember like um
like it changed world rapid i went on
jonathan's tv show like i was going i
was on that big brother program i was on
that big brother program and it was just
like and i was on mtv and stuff like
that i've been clean about a year so
like when you just got off crack and
smack even a year you're brittle and
you're a delicate little bird man you
know i mean they're not all people did
look like that at the time to be fair i
mean i i over emphasized that with the
chrome hair and the eyeliner i actually
went to university with a guy who
literally i met him at the first day of
university because that was like when
you were in that era i was starting to
go to university and there was a guy who
had self-styled himself on you and when
people said you look just like russell
brand he'd be like
that's weird this is amazing he had sex
with a girl once on a canvas who was on
her period and he sold it as art so
congratulations
i feel like you've inspired sort of
commission that's the kind of great art
sorry yeah that was yeah you tell me you
asked for juicy bits of gossip and then
tell a tangential and unusual tale about
a piece of menstrual art you might not
have seen the podcast before but that's
sort of what i'm here for so
tangents yeah i just provide the
bollocks sorry go on about hollywood no
no no no no no
i'm here
because like you were going through
clearly a lot of that time and yet you
are a deep person so you must have
recognized some of what was going on it
must have been too fast yeah of course
it did because you always know deep down
you always know everything it's all in
there the last words of the bhagavad
bhagavad-gita are i remember having had
everything explained to him on the
battlefield arjuna
has been as met krishna who is chosen
above all other possible alternatives
all other possible allies and resources
and the last thing that
that arjuna says after christians said
this is the score don't get distracted
all the stuff you know you we know what
religions are let's not get bogged down
in by the complexity of the vaders he
says that's vader with an a at the end
of darth vader yeah grow up right some
good messages
yeah yeah like don't put that mask on be
nice to your kids um like he says i
remember i remember so like it's all in
there dormant was what i'm saying you're
um you're already home it's already
there it's already all in here that's
the supposed part of the relief but i
remember in a very quick period it must
have been 2006 because it was west ham
liverpool cup final and i remember like
it going from not being famous to being
famous and the things that happened were
i went on jonathan ross and i was funny
on it evidently and i've watched it back
in our it was pretty funny and then like
i um when i next went to upton park
everyone sort of knew where i was i went
out of like proper excuse me famous
woman
around here and like paparazzi and being
outside this building and paparazzi
following us here
it was like
many people that pursue these kind of
like a life of fame whatever there are
some they're proper little artists isn't
it that like just like i just have to do
the acting and i'll do it no matter what
others like me i love the feeling of
connection and performing and making
people laugh but there's no doubt i was
trying to redress some psychological
deficiency through getting attention and
approval
so when that stuff starts to happen when
you're like oh my god that thing i
wanted when i was like you know it just
took it took so long as well because i
first i've done a school play when i was
15 years old and from that moment i was
like this is what i'm going to do this
is me then it takes ages being an extra
agency he's doing stand-up comedy night
after night 50 quid nothing pubs around
here getting barred from that pub around
the corner fighting with people in the
audience not coming off most of those on
most of those occasions like and then
suddenly when it actually happens when
it when there are like photographers
outside your house when they're when you
are going places in fancy cars when
people find you attractive and want to
be with you in a rat like it is
overwhelming it's overwhelming and
you're able to live in a kind of a state
of distraction it's it's difficult to
you know i mean
one obviously example you know everyone
will tell you oh america over there in
hollywood everyone's full of [__] in
that right you've heard that your whole
life right you know that'll be up but
now even if you've never even been there
but when i first went there and i went
around all the studios and i was like
you're fantastic we love you we want to
do whatever you want to do we'll do it
and i was like everyone told me people
know you were full of [__] but these
people are actually really nice and cool
and spot on good judges of character
yeah when you're the center of all that
approval and that attention it's very
difficult to be discerning it's only
after a little while when the true
nature of it is revealed so what it was
like was it was as if what in my mind
one because you're still who you are
when you're a kid no the one minute i'm
a fat little boy and i'm nervous and i'm
frightened that i'm not good enough at
fighting or football and then like next
minute i'm like can do what i want and
go where i want to say what i want a bit
and like everything i do is sort of
important it's mental it's sort of a
giddy thrilling
insane enjoyable thing and it doesn't
surprise me that some people it either
kills them or they can't ever ever get
out of it and they'll do anything to
hold on to it uh it don't surprise me
because it's a powerful powerful drug
i mean you were friends with amy
winehouse and i think you used to drink
around you yeah she was abused like a
beautiful
awake person i see her the first time i
knew it like like
recognized because she was a jazz singer
right i was like who gives a [__] about
jazz i mean like you know and she was i
was like hanging out with like
carl barat and people out of them kind
of indie bands around that time like the
pretty things he was in there because it
was just after libertines but all like
sort of everyone was defined by i don't
know like rifles and um like that lad
what's his name girl with a golden touch
what's that like sort of johnny raise
the line that's them yeah all of that
that's what it all seemed to be
anyway like she was sort of around there
and i thought she was sort of sweet and
lovely and unusual and strange but
didn't pay that much attention then i
went into the roundhouse and she like
did some sort of drop-in thing with
weller paul weller was doing something
and like
just hearing her sing before steve you
know when he like going up just trying
to get into a venue i could have the
voice was so unbelievable and powerful
and then like yeah i saw it for what it
was i saw it before it was she was a
channel man like that's what you get
from certain people they're channeling
you see it in sport and you see it in
art like no one can do that you can't do
that mo salah doing that you can't do
that like that's coming from someone you
couldn't explain to someone how to do
that and her voice was like that
and um you know from then on it become
like i was clean for a little while i'd
see her around it's pretty clear she was
in deterioration i tried to intervene a
couple of times here and then we had
chats and stuff
and i feel like i said to the people
that i should say it to the things that
you would say under them circumstances
like this situation ain't going well in
my view and it feels to me like the most
serious consequences could be at stake
if the most inventive actions ain't
taken
and
it turns out that was right but you know
obviously don't make me a souve say it
makes me able to read the symptoms of
what was
plainly happening and it's yeah it's a
shame it's sort of unnecessary it's um
it's unnecessary it's mental it's sort
of mental illness i know the specifics
of a deaf are to do with alcohol and
stuff like that but into the general
thing is that's addiction that's what
happens if you know we all know people
that are addicts and if you don't take
them out of that if they don't you know
with their obvious consent compliance
obedience willingness take them out of
that situation
then um
yeah that's you know that's how that
ends isn't it weird how um people who
have these gifts who are channels
seem to be also addicts or die early
like it they their light burns so bright
but then it burns out quite quickly um
people like tupac and just even people
have been shot and killed like you know
what i mean but um you know the day she
passed away and you obviously got the
news what was that like for you because
you know you've had this sort of
association with her and you've seen it
coming and you try to say things
and at that point it's like well there's
nothing we're going to do now yeah it's
like a sort of like a record scratch of
what you know like when people die that
you love or care about
it's the
you know that it's inevitable it's
irreversible they're still dead you
realize then when it's something that
you believe is preventable even though
what does preventable mean after the
fact it obviously isn't
you know it
obviously make made me feel that i wish
there were other things i'd done and
could have done and as a consequence of
that now i do try to be very very
present when i feel like somebody's in
that situation and it's happened to me
since then with people there's been
other people and i've i've held in my
mind the feelings of that experience
like from the you know just seeing her
as a person i peripherally knew
recognizing i was in the presence of
greatness oh she's dead now you know
like when i see comparable things i make
myself available i sort of speak plainly
and if if i have the access and
opportunity to do more then i do do more
yeah so like obviously with addiction
specifically that's usually trying to
fill a hole that was probably created in
you when you were younger
a painful one
what was that thing for you that way you
were trying to or was there multiple
things or it's a spiritual thing mate
there's an absence in all of us because
we live in a world that ain't set up for
how we're evolved to live even if you
don't look at it spiritually
we live in a zoo we've got bodies and
diets and systems of consciousness that
were evolved for hundreds of thousands
you know and if you include the entire
evolutionary journey millions of years
to live in harmony with nature i don't
mean that you know they put flowers in
her ear
sit around seeing kumbaya i mean
we can do that also but i mean that we
are evolved to eat the things that are
around us to sort of hunt or gather
depending you know there are ideological
components that actually mean i'm vegan
or whatever but like that's hardly the
issue at this point we're evolved to
live as part of nature we are nature
we've been extracted from nature
and of course i'm not a anti-tech
luddite person but if you live
dislocated from the reality for which
you were conceived
and evolved and some people would even
say designed then there is going to be a
disjunct and a disharmony some people
and in fact the 12-step philosophy that
i use to keep clean believes that the
problem with addicts is they simply
cannot cope without some kind of
spiritual dimension to their life but by
spiritual dimension so you don't think i
mean crystals and candles and [__]
what i mean is connection to who you are
connection to other people connection to
a sense of meaning and purpose and look
at some of the people you know in your
own life how many of them are suffering
because of a lack of connection they
just look like anyone that's an addict
you know what they're doing they're sat
around even if it's people with money
they're just banging stuff up their nose
if it's people with no money they're
banging it in their arm or whatever
people do now drugs have changed since i
was young
but really what they're looking for is
meaning purpose connection these are
ordinary things
and it's bloody obvious isn't it not
evolved to live in this condition this
is like there are things about
technology technological advance and an
all manner of progress that are
beautiful but let's face it when we talk
about progress
what we're actually saying is progress
in a few scientific disciplines to for
the benefit of a particular strata of
society where elsewhere there has been
considerable decline whether you mean
ecologically
socially in terms of poverty and
breakdown you don't need me to tell you
the stats around what's happening around
mental health and suicide and addiction
and does it i mean all these things are
happening meanwhile people are like sort
of excited about a new type of phone or
whatever and
there's great ingenuity in these things
but even an object like this one is
packed with misery direct from the congo
so you have to be awake to what aspects
of reality you're living within me i
felt like i was
i think
we'll never know but perhaps i'd have
ended up an addict no matter what
because you know i had a mom who really
loved me i grew up in what i would
describe as a single parent family i
didn't grow up around my dad you know i
mean
and um
like i think like there is a wounding in
that and i was looking for something i
was looking for something and like once
i found once i started realizing oh my
god you can quiet down that noise
with first for me like weed then booze
then like like i'm like a leaflet from
the government then party type drugs
recreational drugs to eventually crack
an arrow in round there you know like
sort of like once you can numb that pain
or change the way that you feel even
then that is a remedy you are looking to
solve a very particular problem but
there are numerous ways to solve that
problem there would be one another way
is
find out who you are
join a group of people that are trying
to do the same thing as you
connect to a higher purpose that's a
better way of living than dependency on
substances or behaviors it's just
unfortunately harder
yeah first although but like in the end
addiction is harder yeah yeah it seems
easier at the start and then it there's
then it's like there's a bit like i tell
people that are still using it's better
than what you're doing now otherwise i'd
be using with you i'll be using with you
it's better than that because like in
the end it don't work anyway you're
still in the pain you're still in the
misery things are getting worse you're
ashamed of yourself and if you're
hurting people that you love and you
think that you're worthless all of that
can all be remedied it's hard what else
are you going to do with your life some
pitiful trudge to the grave without
meaning what this is it this is it you
know it's like a wake-up call in a way
i'm very grateful lucky to be an addict
because now i've got no choice i've got
no choice for me it's either you know
that pitiful life or become awake
yeah did you ever get close to relapsing
in the time that you've been because
you've been sober for a long time
haven't you 19 years because someone
grabbed the dog before they and my dog
said
someone needs to just keep a hold of him
cheers thanks
he said hello he's all right he loves it
oh he's a good little boy
yeah this is your house
yeah
yeah it's pretty beautiful it's pretty
beautiful do you think i could possibly
have a cup of coffee or something
absolutely like a double espresso
substitute yeah we'll get some we'll get
that no worries while we're sitting here
we're looking at you with coffee we're
like yeah go on you've got i mean that's
a ridiculous this isn't a race
of this if you want a little bit of
something it's like a little strawberry
milkshake you're sweet you are you're a
really sweet person you'll be the uh
british joe rogan and i'm all right
thanks and he's probably got milk that's
sort of my vibe yeah definitely he's not
he's my dad basically but he doesn't
know it as sort of i'm hoping he wants
the job he can adopt me someday
men's mental health territory you know
like of where wellness and fitness meet
with mental health that's the sort of
territory that's what he does he doesn't
think about that but with the bjj and
with the sort of interest in like you
know psychedelics and like and you know
with his
inquisitive attitude and his willingness
to have them conversations he's really
opened up some territory you do bj jay
yeah because of it i did the other yeah
yeah right yeah yeah i do do that you're
pretty good as well i've become
i'm a purple belt now and i've become
better at it but you know what it's like
something like that that you realize
that you're getting better but also that
there's just
some seemingly limitless potential for
ongoing growth and you're always aware
of other people's incredible power like
if you do it like against a white belt
who's done a lot of rugby he's like whoa
bloody hell or if you know like a black
belt that you know any black belt or
brown belt or you know or purple someone
that's like saying belt was me but
younger there's so there's loads and
loads of variables but it's it's put me
in my body like nothing else before it's
changed me did you have any moment of
ego coming in when you started realizing
you could [__] people up who didn't know
[__] yeah i loved that little bit but
that you can't have to know that there's
other people that
can't [__] you up yeah you're on the
other end of that
yeah
yeah it'll keep you in check but it'll
also give you those little windows of oh
right okay because you obviously for
years people will look at you like
you're nothing to worry about because
you're this flamboyant character who
doesn't come across as a threatening guy
but now
you know
if
some of those guys who previously
thought they could [__] you up tried it
you would wrap your arms around their
neck or legs around their neck and
they'd go to sleep pretty quickly
so
do you not just fancy doing that once or
twice
it's reassuring give it a go now see
what happens
unconscious
yeah but i think cause for me it's
become it's come in alignment with all
of those other things it sits pretty
well with it because you have to you
know like you have to say present don't
you with grappling you have to be aware
of every like every specific moment
where am i putting my knee now am i when
am i going to hip out what amount of
pressure is that you know demands of you
such kind of presence so that bit of me
that thinks oh this is my opportunity to
be like a superhero for a moment also
anything when i start thinking like that
i'm punished really quickly i feel like
because i believe in god and all that i
feel like if i'm in the service of
higher things god's got my back and
would everything would go right but if i
ever start going i'm gonna try and
impress people i feel like it will go
bad for me so you you believe in god
what kind of um idea do you have of god
a limitless benevolent oneness that the
consciousness in me right now the
experience of being me looking out of my
eyes at you is the same experience
you're having as well but with the
variants and variations that come from
your individual experience and probably
some biochemical distinctions as well
but through meditation we could achieve
a place of oneness and connection i
believe that god is unity that the
reason that love feels good is because
love is a truth that there is a
connection between people whether it's
the love of newcastle united your dog a
family member or whatever what is it is
a kind of an attempt to unify and
connect with that thing i believe that
the physical realm the material world is
just one bandwidth of reality for which
we have the sensory instruments and
because the only sensory instruments we
have are for this particular material
plane sight sound smell taste you know
whatever
that's that we think of that as the sum
total of reality but it is not
inconceivable that there will be other
instruments that detect entirely
different realms of reality and even
within the stratas of reality that we
can receive we know that bats and
dolphins and whales and other creatures
and cats see other light and hear other
sound so we're living in a curated
reality we know that people that have
psychedelic or near death experiences
encounter reality that's entirely
different there are phenomena that are
excluded continually from the
conversation because if it's true that
we're all one then systems of hierarchy
and domination and exploitation and
destruction would have to radically
review the way that the world is
undertaken if all that really matters is
your life is an individual you're born
you live you die like if that's all
reality is then why bother to cultivate
a beautiful world if the only things are
real other things that you can measure
then why explore the limitless space
within us as well as the limitless space
without us
when we talk about science what we mean
is the area of science that is well
funded no one's spending a lot of money
to discover whether or not inexpensive
substances can heal mental health issues
because we live in a profit driven
society we don't notice or recognize
that we live in a fundamentalist
ideology you know when like sort of
remember 10 years ago when people were
much more sort of scared about radical
islam and stuff when terrorism was the
thing that was used to keep us in check
back then those nostalgic days we talked
about like fundamentalism
now but forget that we live in a
fundamentalist ideology where we're
constantly bombarded with
commercial ideas and an ideology that
continually underwrites that when you
cannot escape screens when you cannot
escape the constant scream of
commodification we live in a radical
society it's a radical try and get out
of it try and not obey it try and live
your own life and then you'll see
what the reality is you live within so
my belief in god is that what we call
reality is only a small piece of reality
and accessible to us within us is an id
is something that is very deep and
powerful c.s lewis he was like he wrote
line rich and wardrobe all that stuff
he wrote a book called mere christianity
and in that book me christianity he says
like look where the values come from
where does it come from the idea that
you're going to be kind to one another
that you're going to be loving he goes
you get one society where a person might
be married to five husbands or wives and
you get another society where people
might just have one wife you don't get a
society where people are applauded for
running away in battle if someone gives
up their seat to you on public transport
and you don't say thank you you know
they ain't right if someone gives you
something you don't give it back to them
you know that something in your body
lets you know
people go out their way to come up with
ideas like reciprocal altruism we're
evolved because in the days when we was
in tribes if someone done something nice
so therefore we're rewarded there's so
much complexity in anatomy just the
evolution of an eye that it's it's
beyond it's beyond material explication
of course you can create a narrative
around anything but the narratives that
we create around a godless atheistic
materialistic universe are
fundamentalist they are a choice it's
not empiricism it's not this is the
facts it's this is a set of facts and by
coincidence this set of facts advances
the agenda of the powerful weirdly so i
believe in god because i believe there
are different layers of reality that are
accessible and i've been in them do you
um because i i'm quite interested i'll
listen to your podcast i think there's a
lot of really great guests on there that
you kind of you managed to explore
people from the the right with the
people like ben shapiro and then there's
people like jordan peterson somewhere in
between that and then there's people on
the left as well
do you think um
do you think there is a
a particular ideology that's getting it
right at the moment like do you think
there is islam or is christianity do you
think those things are
important in the world
i think that it's important to have
a set of principles and values i don't
really have a favorite in fact what i
mostly believe is that people should not
judge other people's sets of ideologies
or lack of ideologies i believe in a
kind of
libertarian anarchism where people
should be able to form their own
communities with their own values and if
you don't agree with those values you
should just go oh cool all right you
know like whether it's people's
gender identity or people having a very
strict religious set of principles if
they're practicing that within their
community and i don't think it's anybody
else's business but in order to
radically change reality there will have
to be some correspondence and some
coordination and some collaboration so
there does at some level need to be a
kind of confederacy
i feel that
ultimately the big distraction that is
continually undertaken is the fact is i
say just take the example of football of
course it's very easy to hate sunderland
fans or tottenham fans or mule fans or
whatever it is that you know but it's
sort of you know really it's kind of a
game because you've got people that you
love that support those football teams
it's an artificial it's an artificial
difference i think these differences are
true with most of the
talking points in the news around
left-right politics etc these days but
what we have to look for
is alliance because
the people in positions of power the
institutions that are powerful benefit
from us continually being distracted by
these minor notes so i think like
if i was hanging out with muslims i
think i'd like listen to them and think
oh yeah these are the things that are
true if i'm hanging out with christians
or buddhists or atheists or whatever
i've got you know ricky gervais has been
on here and he's been on my podcast and
he's like a pretty serious atheist isn't
he but he has morals and values and
loves animals and seems to think there's
something very sacred about animals you
know and like so i just and like when i
went on rogan and he's into hunting and
i'm a vegan i think well i'm not going
to spend all the time arguing with this
geezer about some little trivial point
even though i really really love animals
and i don't think i would be able to
fire a gun at a creature's head i think
that would be really far out for me to
do that but i still feel like why am i
going to sort of like with someone i so
clearly agree with a lot about why would
i bother to argue because that's what
everyone else does so that that's that's
99 of the internet is there's your
coffee
is is disagreeing with each other over
the little things
because to some people that's all they
see
not and
like
who you support that's it's the best
kind of way to distract people from what
is actually important it's also a route
to money if you if you can quibble over
all these little things you can make 10
videos a day and pick up 10 people's
little foibles 50 different times you
can make a lot of money through being
critical of other people which you know
granted i imagine we've done at some
point sort of criticize other people
because we will and it's sort of
something to laugh you kind of got to
know what level you're on in it like if
you're sort of mucking around sort of we
know it's in our hearts don't we we know
it's in our hearts when you're sort of
tormenting someone if you're saying
something that's sort of kind of
comedically mean it's like you know when
you're like ah i'm going to hurt you i'm
relating so hard right now yeah yeah
absolutely yeah did you know about that
that's like lauren i i don't know what
it's like to say something comedically
mean and then have people deliberately
misinterpret that that sort of uh that's
kind of the problem at the moment in
comedy isn't it like i don't know
obviously you hang out with rogan every
now and again do you still find yourself
um hanging out in those comedy circles
as well because there does seem to be a
bit of um well i think council culture
now is making it so much harder to be a
comedian like and you've got great
comedians like tim dillon for example
who was pushing the boundaries
but he's like
the last of a dying breed i feel like
this
the next generation of comedians their
bowls are going to be chopped off before
you even get the chance to get on stage
yes i think so i think that that
what's happening around that culture it
does feel like it's um i mean yeah i
don't get involved in it that's
basically my policy because do you mean
the debate or in the comedy culture i
love comedy culture i love comedians i
love people that look at reality and
want to find what's funny about it or
what's hypocritical about it what's
unusual about it or stupid about it i'll
that's that that's how i look at reality
that's my natural mindset when i'm doing
content like if i'm talking about
something serious like big pharma or fd
fda or if i'm talking about you know
political corruption or what that what
those parties in our country suggest i'm
always trying to look at it comedically
that's that's where i really get my
juice you know i love that stuff
yeah but i
feel like um i don't
wanna like be quagmired in something
about that limitless vacuum of stuff
because i feel like well okay if you
love love if you're happy you know i
don't ever i would hate to think that i
said something that hurts somebody but
but it does restrict you in your ability
to nail things the way they deserve to
be sometimes and if you're having the
nice like let's say you came along now
and you'd started your career now
that would have been chaos oh yeah yeah
you would not have lasted unfortunately
you would have probably been cancelled
called the worst person ever and tossed
aside
and self-destructed maybe that's right
but i think i suppose i suppose what we
have to say is that there are different
like when you talk about say tim dillon
of other comedians that you say are
challenging that ethos i suppose what
that indicates is that there are
different terrains that are opening up
that people can occupy you know and
perhaps it's always been the same
perhaps it's always been that these are
things we talk about these are things we
recognize can't be spoken about publicly
but i would refer like for me that
earlier point is important if there is
love in your heart and you don't want to
hurt people
then then i feel that there should be an
open discourse around that there isn't
because
the way they're the way they're getting
it now is
they they they're killing freedom of
speech in the name of
just just like what they did
what
one great way to [__] people is to
commit things in the name of something
else save the nhs
save the nhs this is what we're taking
away your freedoms for save the end you
don't want to do do what we do
like you're you're a bad person so they
flip it and it's clever and just like
with freedom of speech it's in the name
of you're offending people how dare you
offend people and and it changes the
argument and they put a a slant on it
that now means that we can't just speak
our minds anymore because we're a bad
person if we say things that like what
i've just said about save the nhs and
pointing that out that's pissed someone
off somewhere already i do already know
there's a comment right now i do think
though and this is what i was trying to
sort of wrestle with beforehand because
there is there's like a lot of different
um
aspects to your personality that in most
people's experience of the media
you should be just one of those
dimensions so you should either be the
funny russell the um drug you russell
or the spiritual russell and not many
people
get many opportunities to show all of
those aspects of their personalities
so when you do attack a comedian people
know them as the funny person but they
don't know the spiritual aspect of bill
burr or the human aspect of bill burr
and very often then when bill burr goes
oh well [__] you then then
that people go well he's telling us to
go [__] ourselves so that instantly the
the
narrative is one of conflict straight
away again i think you're right about
that lawrence i think that's a good way
of describing it and just take a couple
of examples that have come up while
we've been discussing it you're looking
for that nhs comment like what we're
talking about with bill burt he came on
the podcast he's like you can just tell
he's that giant-hearted beautiful person
you can kind of see that his personal
circumstances suggest that he would be
um exempt from accusations of racism
that i feel like i've flown around but
he seems to be all right then he seems
to be navigating it you can see what's
in his art he's a beautiful hilarious
person and like ricky gervais said
enough as a brilliant point is when you
say something that's sort of
controversial that that is the joke that
that is the fact that it's insensitive
that's the thing you're honoring it in a
peculiar way
and with your thing about the nhs i
think that's a very good example as well
because while we were being encouraged
to bang pots and pans on our doorstep
what was happening is that it was being
privatized legislation was being
introduced to make it easier to sell the
nhs to american healthcare firms a plan
that's been happening over the last 10
years since
like an earlier incarnation of this
conservative government so while we're
engaged in whether or not we're
certain people are using the right
language and everyone's up to scratch
and whether people are doing the right
things and what's the you know where
we're supposed to stand on particular
registers what's happening is people in
positions of power are cracking on is it
in a way surely you knew that was
happening at the time though because
when you've been around long enough and
you've paid enough attention as i know
you have
when everyone else was getting
swept away in the you know
[__] that was being told it was
about protect the nhs save the nhs and
hit hiding behind that as a way of
controlling people
you know
when when it came out that boris was
having parties with all these cronies
and all of that and everyone's like
the outrage of oh my god i can't believe
he wasn't following his own rules can
you believe this i'm sat there going
you've been paying attention a [__]
course he wasn't the guy is a
bullshitter you actually believed him
what do you want from me well even of
course that level of um discourse is
designed to keep it at a certain level
like so that the result would be maybe a
different prime minister or possibly a
different party but never
like obvious questions like weren't the
function of those regulations to protect
people from a health crisis so not only
is there the hypocritical component but
there is the suggestion that they
weren't frightened to have those parties
how do you um
how do you uh work with conspiracy
theory where you come from because every
now and again i do see in your videos
you sort of allude to
the ikes of the world and those kind of
people or you know that level of kind of
person where does that fit into your
thought process within all this what i
reckon lawrence is like the ideas that
all
some of the ideas that change our
reality and these ideas are here some of
them will come from within the
mainstream some of them will be like
from the great trade union movements and
the power and solidarity and fraternity
that is suggested by those kind of the
changes of the last century that were a
response to industrialization
those things and some of those
traditions are magnificent and beautiful
and will be used but some of the ideas
that change the world are going to come
from outside of the mainstream they're
going to have to because we've seen what
the mainstream is doing so what i try to
look at is
it's like what are they saying really
what is that idea say like you know well
jfk that's a conspiracy theory right
that that wasn't lee harvey oswald that
killed him but the files around that
case have just been booted another 75
years into the future so whatever it
says in those files evidently they don't
want people reading it until like my
kids are octogenarians because it's
offensive if you read that's what's
offensive is the
is the limitless corruption and
duplicity that goes on in the high
levels of power not the um private
choices of individuals and the private
in discrepancies of individuals without
power i always think like before
allowing outrage into you
what power has this person got i know
this is what i used to think with like
when it was a tension between working
class british people uh that were white
and working-class british people that
were muslim and non-white i'd think like
what not these people got any power you
know like when you saw people talking
about sort of brexit and the the
condemnation
and uh
sort of the patronizing attitude towards
people that voted for brexit or whatever
you know i feel like it's only two
generations ago
that you wanted those those class of
people to believe so strongly that
britain was real that you wanted them to
send their sons out to die for that flag
and now if they have it out on their
patio you're taking the piss out of it
like for me i feel that if we are going
to change society we're going to have to
come together in a way that we never
have done before we're going to have to
be open to ideas in a way that we
haven't been before that we're going to
have to countenance things that only
really are housed within spiritual
situations these days sacrifice
discipline willingness to change but the
problem is russell is
fear is stronger than love isn't it and
and if there's one thing that last
couple of years has shown me
it's that
to a degree
people will try and come together
but if it suits them and in their
interests and it's very rare that
everyone's interests are lying
and that'll it feels like just that
divide it'll be very hard to be broken
suppose what we're going to have to do
then is find a set of ideas a manifesto
that would appeal to over 50 of the
people for example in this country
present that set of ideas and say that
if we were in a position to promote and
instantiate these ideas this is what we
would do
then enter into perhaps the existing
systems in a favorable way recognize the
kind of opposition that would likely be
faced anyone that was saying this is how
we would control media this is how we
would control big business this is how
we'd return resources to ordinary people
this is how we would create actual
democracy where you control your own
schools hospitals communities where you
don't have a life work that's determined
by work but it's determined by the
experience of being alive reality can be
a million things it ain't just if you
don't like capitalism you want to go and
live in maoist china if you don't like
the music of mozart ain't no what you
want put your head in a bin and have
someone bang an iron bar on it there's
millions of different types of music
there are millions of types of reality
that can be created and the first thing
that has to be done is communicating
about it the second thing that has to be
done is helping people to believe to
have the faith and the hope that change
is real and possible and then you've got
to believe that stuff because um
history tells us that if you say those
things continuously you will be killed
it seems like you're going one level
above uh where the the narratives
actually say you're not really arguing
about people you're almost in a jungian
sense like going above the archetypes of
that and then saying oh there is a lot
of commonalities between people who are
christian and people who are muslim you
guys should join together there are a
lot of you know
uh commonalities between working-class
muslims and working-class
you know christians or whatever you want
to call them you should you should not
be picking over all the little
differences it's the opposite of that
that's exactly what i'm saying and it's
exactly what i'm saying that there are
archetypal resources we're all doing the
same thing we all care about the things
we care about by definition we all don't
want to die we all love our families we
are all attuned to nature we all even
though there's limitless differences
between us and you can see that by
looking at us we all got bloody
skeletons we've all got kidneys people
ain't that different and i would say is
the same with the archetypal energies of
consciousness even though there might be
variation the structures are the same so
we have to acknowledge that what we're
not we're not striving for perfection
we're striving for something better than
this and if we can't achieve better than
this then uh you know we should give
them you mentioned uh conspiracy
theories i was just about to say yeah
what's your favorite um
now i do like those lizards those
litters are the best ones i've always
been a big fan of them
obviously
david ike was the one who came up with
the lizard people thing and we've had
him on the podcast he's he's fantastic
yeah she's coming my radio show all the
time he's fascinating right and and i
remember you uh you were interviewing
him back in the day yeah um but one of
the things like for example he said yes
it goes microchips one day microchips
and this week
on in the in the name of kovate
microwave chips that that trains never
late uh right on schedule uh microchips
where they can scan you now when when
you read a story like that on your
channel is there an element of you
that's like
a bit frightened of like [__] me they
are getting you know ike was a wrong
about some things but like some of these
things are actually happening now these
silly little theories that everyone
laughed at this guy for are actually
being propositioned as real things yeah
that's right some of them are more
baroque components of that stuff and but
you know and he's very vehement isn't he
david like if you've ever spoken to him
like he likes that lizard stuff and he
believes it's proper legit real um
who are we to argue now you know you'll
notice that
people voices like david aiken alex
jones are sort of removed kind of and
certainly heavily censored these days
but they've been destroyed yeah as best
as they could be yeah it's very
interesting then to
put aside any um emotions that you may
feel about those people and then just
sort of list the things i've said now
because there are so many things but
even take something like terence mckenna
who's not so
controversial because he's not going out
and direct but he's still saying like
he's that guy's a genius prophet
like going on sort of psychedelic
journeys and coming back with some
powerful powerful gear but like you know
like a lot of stuff he says is pretty
crazy as well a lot of things everybody
says is crazy probably if you look at
martin luther king a lot of things he
said and they were probably crazy or
gandy but like
yeah when you look at stuff like some of
the
predictions that we were moving towards
a technocratic centralized dotopia
where technology will be used to limit
the power of ordinary people that
doesn't seem mysteriously untrue it
wasn't a million miles off was it you
know what i mean he nailed it really
pretty it's it's it's it's maybe they're
all lizard people do you know what i'm
saying do you think though that's ever
like um you just look at that from uh
like you know a lot of people talk about
what's the fighter that talks about um
the art dan hardy's oh the reptilian
reptilian thing he talks about
the inside of your brain yeah he talks
about that i guess that could sort of be
in a
an
allegorical way true that these people
are more like lizards because they're a
bit more cold i remember asking but do
you mean this in an allegorical way
yes the actual lizards
like this woman who was like yeah and
then the royal family member shed its
skin and like very much like if you've
ever seen men in black where the
cockroach comes out of the guy right
that was sort of what i was envisaging
yeah before the but then
another thing he was banging about was
like the pedos and the pie society and
all of that like that's literally all
okay so maybe
just go with him on it and also there
are all these area 51s there are
categories called top secret obviously
by the the due to the nature of those
discussions it is a controversial thing
to speculate on but certainly if you
were to confine yourself to simply
looking at facts that do seem to have
been some interesting things emerge but
again we're not talking like the
language of academia we're talking in
the case of alex jones or david ike with
whom there are many things that i
disagree um
there are some
peculiarly interesting insights what do
you think about them being completely
removed from
social media in the way that they have
for example i'm just
my personal
feelings are that one of the best tools
we have
to create a better world is open
communication undertaken in good faith
and good heart that's my personal
feeling
that
we should be encouraging conversations
between people that disagree with one
another so that we can discover that we
are not actually that dissimilar that we
have a lot in common i think that's
where the the like i'm not neither right
nor left but i'm i'm an observer i feel
like you know i'm probably banging the
middle somewhere but when i see you know
the left are always painting that was
the good guys but one of the things that
i'm seeing them do more and more shut
down that argument and talk about
you know donald trump shouldn't be on
twitter and all of that they're not to
me i get
you know you don't like what he's saying
and all of that but i'm with you on that
like it doesn't matter what these people
are saying like if we start
removing people's voices it's a slippery
slope to ending the complete
conversation isn't it i believe that
i believe in
truth and
love and really sort of simple ideas so
i don't
feel that we need draconian
restrictions i think that if we can
create a society where people are loving
and respectful to one another and allow
them to be who they are and uh
understanding intuitively and in an
educated way where possible about the
differences of people's life experience
and sensitive to that i feel like we
need to be afraid of one another
the heightening of fear
cannot be good for our culture it can't
be
this nice to be aware there is a thing
called wisdom fear
where you're that you know fear evolved
in us for a reason to give us a certain
amount of awareness of our environment
and the challenges we would likely
tackle within that environment but
neurotic fear a spiraling fear that
never ends that can never reach a
conclusion that has no real target in
mind but other than its own sort of
serpentine endless coil
maybe that's a bit of hope for us though
because i think the british public
particularly feels so lied to now
obviously the fear that we had shoved up
us
by comparison to the people who were
doing that they didn't have that fear
we're starting to realize maybe next
time these guys tell us there's a fire
we're not going to be as
worried about it we're going to be like
yeah well okay we'll believe it when we
say it next time because they have
controlled this using fiat and i'm
hopeful that now they won't be able to
do that as easily that we've seen what a
bunch of lying bastards they are
certainly we need our own channels of
communication and our own systems of
connection that are not subject to that
degree of censorship and control am i
being told to get out of here now that
am i being told that my what would you
like for another
ten minutes sometime have we got ten
more minutes do you mind if i utilize
this time to promote my yeah go for it
enterprises yeah
having said that we do need to make some
money here so go ahead yeah
this utopia will need some funding so
like i'm touring
and i'm touring a lot in the north of
our
beloved country can i tell you some
places where i'm doing go for it in my
tour hold on if you want you want me to
do this in the list because i'm doing it
open i'm doing this slightly less we
once had gabrielle bon lohr on the show
and he literally went can i talk about
my brand now so maybe we'll just here we
go russell you're on tour at the moment
aren't you oh god i've forgotten about
that yeah tour what do you mean yeah a
tour of the mystical kingdoms of the
inner world also i wanted to say
that's how that's how i feel but also i
would say
this isn't that we've got two links you
can tidy this up like uh
also well with regard to how do we
progress how do we come forward how do
we confront power well it's funny that
you mentioned that because i talk about
these things quite a lot in my tour
oh really you're on twitter you're on
tour oh yeah yeah you should mention
that but if you were interested in
coming to see me and escaping from the
hellish cyber nightmare that your
reality is become i'm in bristol glasgow
nottingham plymouth blackpool like the
ones up until march they're mostly sold
out but newcastle
come see me newcastle there's not much
uptake there so far so if we could just
know that's good for eight o'clock it's
looking good carlisle sand center come
there fifth of april that needs a right
shelf torquey princess fear 29th of
april and hull
hull on the 22nd of may and 25th i'm on
i'm in stoke so go to my website
russellbrand.com come see me
worst patient-to-doctor ratio in the uk
so those guys do need some care there
were some of the things that you did but
what you know it back in the day
and i just don't bring those up
what about my football podcast let's
talk about the football podcast is good
how are you feeling at the minute i'm
fine you must be loving life no because
there's a place today how could that
goal be allowed at old trafford when
almost all of cavani's hand is offside
he's saying it's his entire hat yes it's
a conspiracy yeah
have you ever seen the way cavani's eyes
flicker sometimes he goes in he's an
interdimensional being yeah like no i'm
generally speaking really really happy
are you happy with how are you happy
with tripping are you happy with the
christmas one nil against leeds i i i am
and i'm starting to believe again you
know i'm starting today we might stay up
you're at that part of the cycle
the team are now in saudi arabia
they're taking it we're actually
literally going to go there don't worry
you won't even notice this saudi arabia
oh [__] we're off there what do you make
of that you know the fact that newcastle
have been bought by
you know
a country that doesn't necessarily
promote all the friendliest of values
mate it's a bit like it's a bit like
what we're saying with the conservative
party
conservative parties like it's like
what this is you know for we know what
football is it's a commercial entity
like all things are and like yeah
where's the where do you draw in the
line not dubai but saudi arabia like you
know like the the fact is is that the
systems of economics that we have
prioritized and privileged to chew
through human life that's what they need
to do
so yeah i don't think you can make it
special i mean if you're trying to make
a special case i don't know yeah you've
got derby on the other hand who are
about to go out of business as well so
it's like if you don't
have
a lot of money pumped in through someone
who you may not particularly want owning
your club you could end up going out of
business
if we're seeing the end of the system
that made all these problems
um can i ask you uh to pitch something
to brian
yes i'm always pitching to brian about
meditation and he keeps going i don't
know if it's for me you gotta do it
why well like improve every single
aspect of your life every single aspect
of your life it's the seat of your being
it's as important as exercise it's as
important as eating well you've got to
get to the very kernel not even colonel
because that's a two sort of solid way
of representing it don't mention the
kernel i think of kfc
i'm joking i'm joking and i'm sorry
so you know when you sit there do you so
what do you think about because i know
you do the the voice um
yeah the meditation oh yeah that's
another thing i can promote luminary my
uh such a good idea i signed up to
luminary just for that you're kind
thanks laurence cheers mate well there's
like there's guided meditations on
luminary in my podcast under the skin
and what the reason you should meditate
mate is it'll improve and or every
aspect of your life every facet of your
life you'll have a place to look at
reality from to reflect from what am i
thinking i sit down quietly i check the
body i check i'm not holding tension in
my face in my tummy in my legs
and then i bring my attention to the
breath for a little bit and you'll
notice that when you close the eyes and
relax and bring your attention to the
breath that all your mind is is just
this cycle of force is that joe
dispensary come on my podcast said
ninety percent ninety percent of the
faults you fought yesterday you'll think
again today and you'll think them again
tomorrow within programme conditioned
when you meditate in the part of
practice is to learn to observe them
thoughts and recognize that's the first
layer of the outside world is your force
it ain't even you we think that we are
our force but it's just an external
phenomenon it's got matter it's got
charge it's got energy not matter but
it's got energy it's got weight you know
so like you look at it as being outside
of you
eventually the thoughts start to abate
there'll be times in meditating like
even me i've been doing it 13 14 years
sometimes i think i'm just sat down
thinking with my eyes shut what's this
woman
people describe it sat down thinking
before i should have done that i
shouldn't have done that when am i going
to do that but after a while there is
something else in there and it will
change everything it will change the way
that you fight it will change the way
that you exercise it will change the way
that you feed because
this is it he said eckhart tolle when he
come on because if he was described in
this room you described maybe the
furniture and the people in it but you
wouldn't describe the space your
thoughts and your feelings and your
sensations they're the objects in the
room there is space is consciousness
itself you have awareness you are an
aware being and we don't cultivate or
curate correctly what we put in that
bloody environment fill it up with
claptrap and pawn and crap the whole
time you know we can change it we can
order it and therefore all our reality
itself within the field of your
awareness your personal awareness is all
history you know you've see you watch
the same stuff i watch so you know that
we don't even know for sure that
anything other than your own subjective
experience is real
all of history all your fears about the
future are all held in this field of
awareness as well as your sentience and
your awareness of your own body your
thoughts memories projections all held
in your awareness if you take care of
this awareness you can change it you can
change the environment within which
reality is taking place when you do that
i suppose it unlocks different parts
here i'm not saying it's going to make
you more appealing to whoever it is
you're trying to attract or anything
like that but i remember when i first
started i was a little you know
naturally a bit further back down the
old path and i said to david lynch the
filmmaker and person who set up the
david lynch meditation foundation i goes
um
you know but sometimes i'm like in bed
and i'm thinking will i look at
pornography or will i meditate he goes
meditate first and then the pornography
will be better
exactly
have i found the way in i think you
might have heard of
last minute goals
i get it like but i'm quite a pious
person you know my voice is a bit
annoying so every time i try and pitch
it to brian i feel like it falls on sort
of ears but i feel like i've listened to
guided meditation but you've bought it
so much but i just go to sleep that's
all right you must be tired mate are you
working are you relaxing enough yeah not
really i i i i probably work too much
but um i like listening to um people
talk about things like you're getting
healing from insight and i'm just like
this sounds like some mystical bollocks
but i kind of like the sound of it so it
makes me go asleep you're like ross's
podcast then hey watch it who were you
before you had your name who were you
before you had language i know the
simple answer is a baby but a more
complicated you believe in their
previous lives and stuff like that maybe
i suppose i believe in limitless life
and interconnectivity and perhaps when
people remember a past life is because
they're attuned to some degree to a
particular frequency of consciousness
wow
um
i feel like that was good go listen to
the bloody uh meditation
i guess are we are we
or what time we got what were we like we
i'm concerned about putting the some of
the davidic stuff in and some of the
cancer culture stuff do you edit this
with that i see you got an edit suite in
there do you [__] use it yeah we do
actually not particularly well
are you are you are you worried about
yourself
yeah that sort of stuff like i mean
i just got a nod in the background stay
away from it because i think because
because you're walking in their little
world there you know like
old days well you never endorsed him
though all day long i'll say bring down
the government of course i will no one
cares but if you start like there's like
i'll tell you why you might remember
this well you do remember because you
told me dude when i was doing all that
trousers and i went on paxman's remember
that and he's brilliant thank god god
rest his soul mark fisher brilliant
writer you should read his book
capitalist realism it's little yeah you
read it in in an hour and he explains to
how pop culture is used to keep you
trapped and like how why people are
killing themselves and why people are on
psych meds and why no one believes
anything anymore but it explains it
philosophically he was a professor of
philosophy or whatever at essex
university killed himself always a good
time when brilliant geniuses in their
own lives oh [__] david foster wallace
gone this dude anyway david graber god
rest his soul all these people are
atheists they wouldn't want me god
rested in their souls that mart fishery
stuck up for me during that time when i
had when i went on paxman right and
everyone all the media was mugging me
off and that that fisher goes russell
brand he's a geezer from working class
background he's just took packs when he
mopped the floor with him right i
thought i like this bloke he's sticking
up for me right good so i was really
like touched by him and i loved him and
i love him still well then i was like i
got the hubris as i told you i started
to take myself seriously hold on a
minute instead of recognizing that what
i was doing is i was saying what
everyone was thinking and feeling
and i started to think i'm really
getting across the people here now i
don't think that no more the best you
can do is i don't like be their voice be
their voice don't try to tell them what
to think the people of this country or
the world they know what they think
they're already awake they're awakening
it's all happening okay i started to get
a bit more self-involved and i went on
that paxman again they dumb me up not
paxman though it's the other geezer that
looks a bit like he could be in lord of
the rings without much makeup
he come on and he goes um but what do
you think about 911 now guys i don't
trust the american government
gosh you've got him yes yes it's out
like you know as long as you're talking
about like you know if you're serious
about changing the world if you're
serious about engaging different people
in this conversation you have to watch
where you go and you have to watch what
you say well yeah i can i can see the
change that like because of those
experiences where they they use
something that
you've said to
completely destroy everything else
and that's what they're looking for one
one little comment one little joke about
david one little canteen
it's a shame and for someone as strong
and powerful as what you are for even
you
to now be sitting in this position where
you are saying oh nice strategy man like
if you would like just think of it as
like don't shoot for a triangle early
i mean otherwise you know they'll get
the pass like you know like it's it's
like i know because my ego would like i
should just say what i want but i like
i'm trying to i have humility okay so
there is strategy in this and there is a
long-term goal of
change yes
with through
you know
you using your platform and everything
you've got what what is that long-term
goal
to
empower people and create connection
wherever possible to change their
conversation to help people to recognize
that there are there's the possibility
of creating new systems when the systems
that we have are failing us
that there isn't a complete vision yet
that no society has ever provided a
blueprint for like and this is how the
roman empire is going to be like it's
going to happen incrementally and we can
look at what the phases are and i
believe the first phases are personal
awakening and a willingness to
communicate and form alliances with
people that have a different perspective
that's i think focus there first
except the possibility that any new
political movement might have to pass
through parliamentary process initially
because the avenues are closed recognize
it's going to be necessary to have the
support of the police force the military
the services that you're not going to
change reality if they can just line up
a bunch of people with guns and shut you
down so you have to recognize what are
important to people that have those
roles in life and to recognize the
sacrifices they make and the service
they provide that is why i love the
military and the police force and i'm
right on side with them and they'll
always be supported under our
administration like
so i think it's take it very very slowly
very very carefully populism ain't a bad
thing you know like if you're
if you're able to change the shape of
the conversation in this country if
you're able to water power if you're
able to create voices against the
institutions that evidently clearly
plainly dominate at the moment
then you have to do that responsibly
jeremy corbyn become the leader of the
labour party he just got squeezed out
like a little zit you know i mean like
anything that could potentially provide
any legitimate opposition is closed down
and look at what the party has reverted
to for a minute in my personal opinion
that kind of previous century socialism
isn't the answer that's just personal
opinion i'm not i ain't been a
university but my feeling is is that we
have to have a response to
the technocratic
we have to respond to technocracy the
way communism responded to
industrialization so like we're going to
have to
get new ideas discuss new ideas make
them accessible to a wide range of
people and inspire them to feel hope
again to feel hope again and that won't
happen if everyone who's presenting
alternatives
meaning even in our own little way us
free gets booted off the internet
because they've made some stupid comment
i guess one of the things that
is before we wrap it up uh one the way
you've repositioned yourself now is in a
different way not less trying to
be confrontational with the system and
more trying to
influence from the sidelines a bit more
um
do you not sometimes think [__] it i
want to i want to be more direct and
and be a bit more in your face to a lot
of these people like because right now
you have a
i guess you connect with people in in of
all ages and you're in a really unique
position and people like boris johnson
they're there to be shot at it's like
fishing a barrel never has this been
more of a an opportunity the way i look
at you right now anyway for you to be a
bit more um to seize power in some way
or shape or form if you wanted to go
down that road
well i recognize my i have been shown
humility through humiliation and i've
been taught like
about my own fragility and i recognize
that anything that's coming through my
little ego is of no real value to me or
anybody else so what i'm interested in
creating is alliances and strength and
support and structure
i of since i was a little kid always
wanted the same thing i've always wanted
to realize truth authenticity and
integrity and i want it still now and i
understand things better than i think i
ever have done i just think we have to
be very
i'm
more circumspect i believe things will
emerge i think it will happen and it
might happen really suddenly and quickly
i just don't i don't know so i'm just
trying to be ready i'm trying to be
ready but i'm not like my intention is
not well hopefully i'll get to live a
nice quiet life in the country i mean
that's not the plan
right okay because obviously you're a i
love that you're a family man and a kid
i've got a dog of course 10 cats and we
might get another one how do you fit
time in for meditation
get the hell out of there meditate i
don't talk to those people don't catch
those children that's a joke
see that one they would have that one
time i went i think i went in some
newspaper if i went and i do change
nappies but my wife changes more russell
brown checks his pick don't you know
[__] this lot [__] them forever they
love that they're dead um i'll wrap it
up now because we're getting the uh the
sign um right behind me final question
oh this is yeah uh how would you like to
be remembered i suppose all fantasy
authenticity integrity humor these are
the things that i'm still going for
these are things i'm still going for i
don't think too much about that
someone's have a little fantasy about
god i hope it'll be like diana's funeral
but then i think come on mate calm it
down we'll all cry elton john there well
that'd be lovely yeah
england's rules dodie
yeah
the bottom of an escalator in harrods
you'd be incredible for that what
innocent victims that's what it says on
that statue that you're referring to to
be fair we're talking about sound swans
yeah
yeah this one's we're involved in if we
all end on a conspiracy theory diana
there you go
look into it just saying um this was
russell brand on the true jordy podcast
what a beautiful man thank you for
coming on me thank you appreciate it
well done for everything you've done
what an achievement well done
and also we have a football show we i
know the boys would love to have you on
our uh live football show that we do we
do like how many shows do you do uh a
lot i got a fighting show poker show
football show podcast fighting podcast
gaming you work every day pretty much
yeah yeah do you have weekends off no
the opposite we work the weekends
especially yeah i'd love to have you on
a west ham game that'd be sick all right
you do like what we watch yeah we do
like live watch parties sort of thing
yeah that'd be good for that um
unless you like poker do you like pogba
he's just he's just having a little
you're just sort of obsessed in the room
did you make your dinner yeah uh but i
order it of course you do
you maniac you great man
you know what i mean there is a
microwave in the corner yeah you know
it's not he can cook some of his own
cross between big and forest gump you
know um life is like a box of chocolates
don't forget to subscribe thanks for
watching and actually don't forget to
subscribe and can i do some promo
absolutely done
sign up to my channel believe in
yourself god is great we can overthrow
the government come and see me on tour
on the website can we come and see you
at all come from yeah of course whenever
you want to come on amma smith on the
first you give as many tickets as you
want although it is sold out yeah i
might come to i might come to hull just
you know get the crowd come to all yeah
do the warm up
i'll need you now
thanks for watching and we'll see you
later cheers thank you